let's get more on that wavering guidance
from the cdc by talking to our david
agus who joins us now
dr akus good morning to you so the cdc
was already saying that the virus
spreads easily and rapidly between
people but it was focused on the
droplets that hang in the air as opposed
to these aerosols which float i guess
for hours
how big is that distinction
well you know the droplets are within
six feet when you and i speak droplets
come out and we know that is the
dominant mode of transmission of the
virus
period that being said aerosols the
virus can float in the air
linger longer and further that may be a
mode of transmission it's not the
dominant mode but it may be a mode of
transition we just don't know
what you're seeing is the sausage being
made for the first time in front of the
american public
right we are learning the science as we
go and this is new
we normally know the science because
viruses have been around for a long time
as other diseases
but here we're learning as we go do you
think the
cdc given the challenges it's had
recently with maintaining public trust
should have just kept the guidance up we
heard dr ulster home from
the university of minnesota say actually
this is good science
it was fine why not publish it
you know what's interesting is that
science going up on a website and then
literally a day or two later somebody
finding that and putting that into the
media
i do think is the wrong way to go i
think that there needs to be a
conversation whenever there's a change
explain it in detail because there are a
lot of policy implications
for changing that guidance and so i
think that we deserve a conversation we
deserve an explanation of what are the
data
and why not just to change on a website
so how would our lives change if this
guidance became
the new rule of the cdc that this was a
virus spreading
through aerosolized particles
well it would change how we isolate
patients in a hospital for example and
they would need specialized rooms
and that have specialized ventilation
which we don't have that many of them in
the country
it would change some of the requirements
for opening schools restaurants
uh indoor places um to require certain
ventilation requirements that
are now not always there in many of
these establishments
so this is a big policy change if it
goes through
i think discussion needs to happen all
right so but for the moment we're
thinking droplets and we're thinking six
feet no more and we await uh
further word from the cdc and dr david
agus thank you very much well and
we're thinking masks and we're thinking
mask of course yeah
and they block aerosols they block
everything goes without saying
all right thank you very much dr aegis